hands go bros my name and pit as you can
see I'm going somewhere I'm going to
Italy tomorrow had a busy day trying to
get videos ready in advance for you guys
god dammit you don't deserve it but I
thought I will vlog along the way it's
been a while since I did a vlog smash
that like button if you like vlogs also
check out the giveaway that I'm doing
$100 Amazon gift card but that's it I'll
see you
[Applause]
hey I got some problem with the memory
card but we're going to Mesa
for some things that in a beat that
again I squeeze
your teeth
got'em depicted okay we're going to be
say it probably looks like [ __ ] and it
sounds like it hits my camera bro right
wearing that keep forgetting where we
are things that were impeding first
thing it is this lovely air B&B it looks
like I have lipstick I can see you're
creeping in the back wow so cool oh my
god
that's incredible I like that one more
than the tower I like that one is really
cool never even seen it is a bad that I
really really wanted to fall I feel like
that tower should not be standing
something is wrong Marcy is doing the
classic
shameful shameful myself am i doing it
again that's pretty cool
Haim right yeah okay
what are you gonna do blonde Frank me I
think I don't know where we are I feel
so lost so we're heading back home now
I managed to find in a supermarket an SD
card so Polly that will work so I can
film them a good camera tomorrow so
that's all we're doing for now so hey
human ticket stuff
look at that no well we bought they
really did oh yeah water
the answer is approximately what are you
are you talking to my you can take your
so lame why are you filming
stop this log I'll see you tomorrow hey
hey last one do it for real like that's
a little bit that way
that's Alec cool why don't I do it like
kick
yes at this bar that's cool right this
call hmm am i doing it what am i doing
in Apple am i doing it now there's
bunnies in this garden that we don't
know why please love me
you think you'll like this okay pick
honey please please love me
okay
whatever I don't care whatever bunny is
it working it's working now Hey
and we're matching day - we're still in
pizza but we're going - I'll get it
via Nigel let's go it's so trippy it
looks like it's moving uphill motion
stinks is looking at it we go animate
way it's more fun to look at the
tourists the National Building wait look
at this I'm old man aah oh my god I look
like my dad oh my god I'm so young what
about a girl damn damn
let's see myself what no difference
Bobby eyes whoa those waves are huge
we're at the beach now I don't know why
or what we're doing I don't speak
Italians I'm just following along trying
to understand what people are saying but
we're here now
[Music]
yeah boy I'm taking you to the water
I think I'm JimBob like no one's
watching oh my god I'm Tommy
what'd ya say mice and made your
Playland
oh my god what am I doing here what's
happening
good ride you Pig thing that's pretty
good can I come on barn it's a room for
one more
no wow oh my god you think I'll die okay
yeah boy oh oh [ __ ] that was scary too
fast for me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so we kind of we kind of snuck up on the
ceiling until we get caught got an
amazing view though
[Music]
so apparently it's low season right now
this is not a lot of people apparently
I'm so sick of people there's too many
people here there's so many like student
groups as well and they see me and rich
it gets crazy
oh my god they got married down there
we should bet on them
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to the final day feelings have
no idea what's going on vlogs we're in a
new city now and that's about all I know
having a great time actually really
liked the architecture architecture
looks cool
this Hill is crazy I wonder if I can sit
on the bag and then go down it's too
safe
no terribly if I drop my bag here it
will kill them all right now it's going
upwards head uptown work got to me
thank you much therefore the house
creaks eh eh
[Music]
[Applause]
okay so now we're at the dome very
pretty cool we now we seen that okay
[Music]
very but very very pretty
[Music]
do you like it pretty it's good right
you have a bottom here that's how I roll
can I get a licorice I've been hooked on
these licorice but they still return my
saliva veins are like oops
I just got yelled at by my pimp my god
Marcia we're gonna be a rich father look
at all that money
no more hatred no more you should put a
time this is the final vlog and the
final B do you ever feel like a plastic
bag sweeping from spawn in the sub-game
[Music]
so here we are and it's so tiny it's so
small oh my god it smells so bad
smells like a I [ __ ] my pants I don't
want to go in there terrible I think I
changed my mind
it's supposed to be like a hot spring
but it's more like a [ __ ] smiling spring
all right let's check out the
temperature all meal deal it's so hot
it's actually pretty hot FX is pretty
nice I can get down with it
okay I don't really want to go because
it smells like [ __ ] but I will go anyway
[Music]
thank you now you know you get me
farting but no no now you tell them all
that was pretty nice did you like him
champ what now excuse me while I joined
the two Hawks I was that cringing yes
okay thank you all right last day in
Italy is over we're traveling back home
tomorrow to see the pugs
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm so happy to be home
it feels so good it was a nice trip but
nothing like good old sweet home now
we're going to get the pugs but yeah I
hope you enjoyed this vlog I feel so
ready to just get back to making videos
I don't know when this video goes up but
the time times are weird right now on
YouTube like there's a lot of issues
with a lot of things that's really I
feel like it was good for me to get a
break from it but now coming back I'm
[ __ ] ready leave a like everyone
smash that like button let's can we get
a couple hundred
[Music]